[Música]
o paulista mais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer seu papel aqui que o
homem no bairro
[Música]
então vamos lá contar sol primeiro
precisar de uma folha a4 com impressora
duas léguas um marcador e alguma coisa
para juntar as asas mais para frente
podem dar três pitta então cola button
ea primeira coisa que você tem que fazer
é dobrar esta foi a mãe tem cores
cantando em cima do outro
como em cuidado depois ponha o dedo
deslizem para este lado e segura e
pulgar no outro carro mas já está tudo
bem colocado se estiver só vincar desta
forma vai ficar bem vincado podem usar
uma renda fica muito melhor desta forma
vamos abrir e fica assim mais dobrado
para ficar tudo oferta pelo paraná e
outra vez e realizar desta forma agora
vamos fazer dois triângulos retângulos
toda a linha do centro como esperado não
estou vergonha então vou dobrar no ceará
- mas vocês podem pôr a cabeça mais
perto e ver comigo
quem vai desta forma
agora vamos fazer o mesmo para o outro
lado é muito importante ficar semestre
se não ficarmos leão vai adquirir para
um usuário
agora para finalizar é só brincar vai
usando a rio poderá contrário e vou
morrer 400 de bico para frente é só
vocês podem a régua selado e marcar
usando o marcador
agora temos que dobrar informa que está
ficando aqui fica contactar com a marca
que nós fizemos aqui ou seja um canto
tem ficar em cima da marca quando
estiver tudo ajustado deste lado você
tem que se preocupar com linha do centro
tem que haver uma continuidade da linha
que vai entreter os dois triângulos
ravinet ficando mais da folha
vou colocar aqui cabeça um pouco para
ver se está tudo bem porque o espaço é
muito importante quando estiverem por
sobrar com dois dedos desta forma e
brincando com muito cuidado e com vocês
já devem estar alinhadas e muito franco
tarde a régua nessa dólar
a roupa para mim aquilo maio para vocês
verem melhor com uma régua vamos ver com
o centro e mãe para um dos lados fazer
uma pequena marca aqui no brasil desta
forma o papel vai dobrar a nossa marca
de possuem dentro de mim vai ser canto
vai ficar na linha do centro do nosso
adianta ter portanto verificar isso está
na marca está no centro quando estiveram
configurar por dois dedos que brincar
com outra mão para fazer esse lado é
muito mais fácil basta vocês colocarem
este canto pra tocar no canto do outro
lado vai instalar tudo bem se estiver
pessoa brincar desta forma nesta fase é
muito importante vocês brincarem frutos
da nossa régua é isto porque vamos fazer
agora dobras maiores e basta uma coisa
estar mais em casa para o avião do
espírito germânico bandeiras azuis vamos
dobrar este canto para dentro dizendo
que esta beneficia em cima dessa aqui
[Música]
proponham e vem tem planos de tite
agora vamos dobrar o maior está tudo e
métrica ou seja só uma ralada quando
está sendo proposta uma outra uma delas
for maior então vocês fizeram mal não
vale a pena continuar
agora nós sabemos que aprendemos com 80
e mais importante e demos antes de
entrar temos um dia de dois centímetros
que já testei várias medidas e esta e
funciona melhor
agora nós temos que fazer com um
movimento que liga o centro e mais à
frente
com os dois em tempos de trás ontem a
régua desta forma e dobra
vocês podem tentar fazer sem a régua mas
facilita bastante terem ao comício
em dublin para marcar melhor linha e
temos que fazer o mesmo para o atraso
agora do outro lado é muito mais fácil
basta vocês sobro porém há outras que
fizeram anteriormente na cabeça perto e
verificar a estatura americano com cani
dos palmares nesse encontro um sinônimo
de brincar algo pelo dezembro
não sei quantas vezes disse e pronto
vocês podem ver já está mais ou menos
feito mas ainda faltam as coisas mais
importantes para ele voar com vocês
viram no início do vídeo
vocês mandarem eu vai abanar o aspecto
caí por tempo de dados muito grande e
essa parte em baixa muito pequena então
o que nós vamos fazer é reduzir
ligeiramente atrasados e aproveitar essa
redução para dar uma tranquilidade a
ouviam usar duas águas agora
em uma delas a encostar mas do avião ea
outra vai deslizando em paralelo desta
forma e depois vamos deixar mais ou
menos um sentimento de lado e vamos do
brasil e como podem verificar aqui o
nosso estabilizador é ligeiramente maior
à frente
isso porque na batalha judicial nos
colocarmos um sentem mais à frente e
dois atrás do ceará se virado para baixo
a 90 graus
vamos fazer esse gol veio deste lado
esta parte é a mais difícil de todas
então façam com muito cuidado
a juíza olhem por outro lado que vocês
quiserem ser ainda mais precisos podem
usar a régua para medir o fizeram do
outro lado e fazer igualzinho do outro
basta de encarar este lado e vamos
terminar o nosso avião mas atenção não
basta fazer isso tudo acontecer tem que
saber também como lançar corretamente
já de seguida eu vou mostrar os como
lançá lo
aí vocês podem mandar o diálogo assim
sem usar nada as pimentas boa vai nos
guiar e podem experimentar usando um
pouco de fita no mais do avião perder a
diferença
às vezes eu vou melhor sem fita outros
com fita anos o último deles boava
sempre melhor com fita no maio e pequim
defende bastante para lançar bem vocês
têm que acompanhar o momento do avião e
legal só no último instante
dessa forma
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e protoss campos os rios espero que
vocês tenham gostado que quiserem usar o
canal basta você deixar um posto ae
e se quiserem também podem deixar
sugestões do projeto nos comentários que
o grêmio fez muito obrigado até a
próxima que tal